And there are 2 correct answers here.
One is that we can use non determinism to guess a shortest tour.
It's not totally obvious how to do that, because the if-better function
always can only do 2 distinctions,
so you have to find a clever way to use that function to guess
how to construct a shortest tour,
but it's possible in the way that I've showed you here.
Then once the shortest tour has been guessed,
checking if the length is shorter than
D, and as you'll remember, D was the maximum length that we allow for it,
because we are having shortest tour in the decision problem.
Once the shortest tour has been guessed,
it's easy to check if the length of that tour is smaller than D,
so by easy, I mean it's possible in polynomial time,
so this one here is also correct.
Non determinism can be used to guess
which vertices to put in the tour
is--obviously doesn't make sense, because all vertices are part of the tour.
It's the order of the vertices
that matters for solving shortest tour.
And then the final one, of course, that was easy to see that
it's not really a viable answer,
but I wanted to point out to you that
even though it might sometimes be obvious,
you should always make sure
to explicitly show that the problem is in NP,
and we'll actually, later in this course,
come across some problems where you might initially think that they are in NP
but actually they're much harder than problems that are in NP.
So now, we have completed the first step.
We know that shortest tour is in NP
and now consider finding a polynomial time reduction
from an NP complete problem
to show shortest tour is NP complete.